talk
I believe that an enemy is coming from
far away I'm looking for warriors this
stranger hey everybody as requested this
is gonna be my Justice League deleted
scenes an alternate storylines video for
all the stuff that got cut out and all
of the changes to the story that was
made through the process of making all
the reshoots so just careful for
spoilers for everything that happens
during Justice League there's also a new
round of the imax ticket giveaway going
on all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just for a generic movie you
can use it for any movie that you want
because there's so much stuff happening
between now and the end of the year but
the deleted scenes really fall into one
of two categories they're just cut for
time in a scene that was already in the
movie like you see Superman talking to
Lois there's a longer versions of that
scene that were just cut for time and
then there are other scenes that were
cut wholesale because they're part of
deleted storylines the black suit
Superman of it all the whole MacGuffin
of the mother boxes the cosmic nature of
the story so there's the Zack Snyder
originally intended story then there's
the one that you got on screen because
of all the changes they made so we'll
start with the really big stuff first
especially the deleted storylines
because some of the things are really
fascinating but you can understand how
some of it is way darker than what they
wanted to do so some of the reshoots
were intended to make the movie a little
bit lighter
the mother boxes themselves Steppenwolf
keeps saying mother when he's talking to
them like there's an actual person
inside the mother boxes he's actually
speaking to his mother hey grrah whose
essence is contained in the mother boxes
in in the original version of the story
he was going to combine the boxes
release her and use her power to defeat
Darkseid and become one of the new gods
there's black suit Superman that was cut
out because his entire storyline in the
movie was completely changed with a few
scenes from the original Zack Snyder
footage kept in so one example of a
scene that was always in the movie was
when they're fighting him at the
monument and he does the do you bleed
line that's from Zack Snyder but you can
sort of see the seams of the movie when
he says that because a confused Superman
wouldn't be snarling like that like very
clearly there was part of an evil
Superman storyline and that all has to
do with the way he was resurrected in
the deleted storyline remember two keys
from Batman V Superman
there's the flashpoint sequence where
Batman has the nightmare vision then the
flash comes back it's sort of like their
flashpoint scene where he tells him
about Lois Lois becomes the big gun that
he uses during Justice League it at the
end of the movie you see the dirt rising
off of Superman's grave but what did
that have to do with them bringing him
back during the actual theatrical cut
that was nowhere in the movie like they
completely changed the way they brought
him back so very clearly there was a
very different Superman storyline there
are a whole host of scenes from the
original trailer Zack Snyder showed off
a comic-con a couple years ago that
didn't make it to the film that's very
clearly from the original Snyder cut
before they ever thought about doing
reshoots so there's the shot of Batman
on the horse as he's going to see
Aquaman for the first time they just
sped through that storyline to get
through things faster but then Jason
Momoa has explained that there was a ton
of Atlantis stuff that they cut out
there was a scene with volcko played by
Willem Dafoe's character he's sort of
like the science advisor to Aquaman as
he's king of Atlantis the scenes
basically explained their backstory how
he had been taken to Atlantis and nobody
wanted him because he was this
half-breed
there was another scene after he gets
done arguing with mera where he goes to
King at lands statue takes the armor and
the Trident and then goes back to help
the Justice League all that was cut out
there were a whole bunch of flash scenes
that were cut out some of them have
leaked online since then there was a
scene in a cafe where he's getting
coffee and then breaks through that
window because he hears the car crash
and saves iris West
that was her brief scene during the
movie so they just cut that out
wholesale there was also the flashpoint
scene where he goes back in time to tell
Batman what to do and how to defeat the
evil Superman Lois is the key it was
very clearly a setup for Batman to learn
that the big gun he needed to use at
this Monument scene was Lois Lane
probably one of the biggest ones is
towards the end of the movie when Alfred
is standing there working on something
and someone comes into frame and he says
he said you would come and people are
like who is that is a Green Lantern is a
Supergirl the whole thing is that was in
ten
to be a Superman before Superman goes to
Russia to help them out so it was sort
of him getting the information about
what the team was up to because he'd
been on the farm that whole time so it's
not like they're all calling each other
on cell phones like somebody called
Clark
tell him we're headed to Russia he had
to go learn that from Alfred there was a
whole bunch of JK Simmons that was cut
out remember the scene when they're in
the subway fighting Steppenwolf in the
setup for that they make this reference
to this tunnel that stopped construction
in 1926 because of some crisis that
happened that was all part of a world
building thing that they started between
metropolis and Gotham City back during
Batman V Superman that all got brushed
over in that whole subway scene when
cyborgs like here's the map this is
where we need to go to this place here
they just make a reference to something
that happened back during the 20s cyborg
was probably the character that lost the
biggest number of scenes just explaining
what's going on with his character
showing off his abilities there was that
Batman 1989 shot where the batwing flies
up in front of the moon cyborg did a
version of that his full helmet comes on
they cut that out that was also during
that subway scene and then there's
another scene when they're in the
Batcave talking about the mother box
where cyborg reconstructs this Nazi
encampment digitally in there talking
about mother box related things they cut
that out wholesale probably some of the
coolest stuff that got cut out was that
big flashback fight with Steppenwolf
Robin Wright Penn's character Hippolyta
had dialogue during that it explained a
little bit more about the history of the
DC Universe the cosmology what was going
on with Darkseid the new gods the old
gods at the beginning of the movie when
Steppenwolf boom tubes into the--
mascara and Telsa pauletta then you will
finally love me like after he conquers
the earth part of the dialogue they cut
out from that big flashback war is sort
of set up for that like what his
relationship with Hippolyta was but they
also cut out a bunch of Batman and
Wonder Woman scenes there was that scene
where they're talking about recruiting
people after he goes to see Aquaman the
first time so there were a lot more
Batcave scenes before the team came
together the scene where Bruce is
shaving his beard off was actually
filmed inside his house that was
originally intended to be a different
set they just turned it into his
airplane there's the scene of cyborg
saving the old Jimmy
Olsson guard that was probably during
the big Superman fight at the monument
so they just changed that and they put
him inside the prison all of the scenes
where Batman is driving the Batmobile
around in the streets taking down
parademons with the help of the other
Justice League members was in a
different location
they changed the CG so originally this
was at night somewhere in a different
city they changed it to red to make it
seem more like daytime I think just to
make it brighter but originally most
people think that this was not intended
to be the big final battle the original
Superman story like I said was much
darker much more in just to see if you
play the game you've read the stories
you know he rips the Joker's heart out
it's like one of the most hardcore
Superman panels you've ever seen like oh
my god he's gone crazy originally the
belief is is that that was the way they
were going to defeat Steppenwolf but in
the theatrical cut of the film they take
him down by getting him to feel fear so
he's not dead when he's taken back to
Darkseid and apocalypse arguably for
some retribution so then the movie ends
there's no Darkseid stuff they do the
two post-credit scenes but aside from
having a longer version of that
Deathstroke post-credits scene the only
big thing they changed was Joss Whedon
swapping in the flash vs. Superman race
that was done more in service to bookend
the film and make it feel like less of a
setup for the next film like originally
you probably remember they were gonna do
part 1 and part 2 of Justice League part
2 was gonna be all Darkseid stuff so if
you're wondering why they changed so
many things the idea is is that they had
this you know Zack Snyder trilogy that
they were intending to make but when
Batman vs Superman came out they saw the
critical in the popular reaction to and
they're like okay we need to tweak this
they saw how people reacted to Wonder
Woman so they're like okay we're gonna
give people what they want but they had
already done so much work on Justice
League they literally started shooting
that movie as Batman vs Superman was
hitting theaters so they didn't know
what people thought of Batman V Superman
when they started working on Justice
League so by the time they found out and
then they knew what they wanted to do
with the movie they had already done too
much work on it to completely change it
so a lot of fans and a few people behind
the camera have asked for a Zack Snyder
cut of the film like give us the
four-hour cut they haven't said whether
or not there
actually gonna do that what they might
do is just do extended versions of
scenes they cut for time instead of
doing a completely different cut of the
film because like I said the film the
Zack Snyder shot is a completely
different story than what we actually
ended up with on screen but let me know
in the comments what's your favourite
deleted scene or a deleted storyline and
I know a lot of people are asking about
what's going on with flashpoint now
because they confirmed that Batman is
going to be a part of that I will do
another flash flashpoint video in the
next couple of days I've already done a
couple there in my Justice League
playlist so you can just scan down that
I'll link it at the end of the video but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Eduardo and please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
was a new round in this video I'll just
announce a winner - the next time I post
a DC video so you can click here for
last night's flash and you can click
here for all my Justice League Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight